And the nice thing
about learning bslib
is it serves as a
general foundation
that not only Shiny and R
Markdown directly can use,
but also extension packages
like flexdashboard,
and pkgdown and bookdown, like
some of these other packages
that fit into the
ecosystem and essentially,
like extend R Markdown
or extend Shiny
because of how we've sort
of approached this problem.
So at least, a handful
of these packages
have pretty nice seamless
integration with the ability
to like if you have a
theme that you're already
using for your
Shiny application,
you can pretty
easily sort of copy
paste that over to
a flexdashboard app
or your pkgdown website
or something like that.
If you're using
bslib, make sure you
have a more recent version
of Shiny and R Markdown
when you're using it.
And the real
straightforward basic usage
is to take advantage
of this theme argument.
If we're talking
about Shiny, there's
a few different ways to create
sort of the page container.
So if you want that
classic navbar page look,
you would start
with navbar page,
and give the theme argument
to this bs_theme object.
And with this
bs_theme function, you
can specify the bootstrap
version that you want to use.
So I think still we're
defaulting to bootstrap four,
but soon we will default
to bootstrap five.
But if you want your project
to be fully reproducible,
we do recommend like fully
specify the version so
that if we change the
default in the future,
you won't be surprised that
you're getting a new bootstrap
version.
So this is kind of
like the easiest
way to opt in to a
new bootstrap version
is to call this bs_theme
function, give it a version,
and pass it to the theme
argument of a page layout.
And the equivalent
way of doing something
like this in R Markdown
is to work with the theme
arguments of a output format.
So not all output formats
will have a theme arguments.
This historically has just been
used for output formats that
are HTML-based and
theme has historically
meant like choose a different
bootswatch theme essentially.
So you might have used this
and said something like theme
Darkly or theme Cyborg
or some Bootswatch theme,
but we've now extended this
interface, essentially,
with bslib so that you
can provide any collection
of arguments to this
bs_theme() function with all
of your custom
theming parameters.
And then essentially,
this HTML document
will use all of
those custom settings
to influence the CSS
that goes on the page
in the same way that would
happen for the navbar page.
So that's one of the great
things about learning
via bslib once, is you could use
it in both of those projects.
You just have to kind
of work around the fact
that this is YAML,
and not R code.
So some of the things that
you might be more easily done
over here in the R side might
be a little bit trickier
to convert that to pure YAML.
If you have more recent versions
of bslib and flexdashboard,
bslib itself comes with some
different templates in RStudio.
So I could show
you how that looks.
If I go to File,
New file in RStudio
and then go to R Markdown,
this little window will pop up.
And then if you choose
the From Template option,
bslib will provide a few
different examples of how
to get started with R Markdown.
And I believe-- I don't
know if I have the newest
version of flexdashboard,
but we also
have some flexdashboard
templates that show you
how to use bslib with it.
So if I just open that one, this
will give me a more worked-out,
complete theme.
And so it's not going to be
super clear or super obvious.
Like, one unfortunate way
about how this currently works,
which we're looking to
improve in the future,
is that, how am I going
to remember what arguments
go to this theme parameter?
I'm using bg here, which
represents the background
color, fg which
represents the foreground
color, a primary
color, secondary,
and a couple different
font settings.
And I guess the way that
I keep track of this--
and I'm hoping other people
will remember this as well--
is you can pass in any argument
to this bs_theme() function
to this theme YAML
setting over here.
So as you can see, the first few
listed are the bg, as I said,
a color string for
the background;
fg, color string
for the foreground.
There's a handful of different
accent color settings.
So primary is going to be
the most obvious one that
changes the most colors.
But then it's also possible
to control some other colors
with these other
accent color settings.
There's three different
main settings for fonts.
So the base font is going to
be kind of like the global font
setting for everything
on the page.
Code will target code
blocks, essentially,
headings for things like
titles, and then you
can also do some
things like scale
the fonts to larger sizes.
And eventually,
we'll get through--
talk about the fact that there's
actually hundreds of different
theming controls that you
have access to via bs_theme().
But they're not all
named arguments,
and we've kind of intentionally
designed things that way,
where we want to
allow you to set
any of these main
color and font settings
and have it work across
the board on all Bootstrap
versions.
But then when you
get more targeted
and set a more specific style
on a very particular thing
on a website, we want to
make it a little bit harder
to discover those things and
make you aware of the fact
that this could potentially
break with a newer
version of Bootstrap,
and we're not
committing to supporting
this across the board.
So let me actually just
show you a real example
of what's going on here.
So let me just knit this.
All right, so this
is the template,
or the result of that template.
So that main bg setting is
going in and determining
this background color here.
The foreground color,
I believe, will be used
for these text colors here.
And the thing about implementing
a dark theme like this
that you might want
to keep in mind
is there's actually at
least tens, if not hundreds,
of actual color styles
that are going into the end
result on the page.
So for example, the gray on
this background for this code
block is actually like a
mixture between the background
and the foreground color
that you're choosing.
So when you give us
those two main settings,
you want it to be kind
of a high contrast
difference between probably
two grayscale colors.
So that's why I recommend--
first of all, it's
primarily most
useful for just implementing
a dark theme like this, where
you just set the background
to something that's
close to black and
foreground that's
something close to white.
Then you can easily
have a dark theme here.
But I think people
quickly want to set colors
with different hues, like
a green for a background
or something like that.
And just be careful if you want
to do something like that--
you want to set a dark green--
choose a lighter green
for the foreground color,
and don't choose a light
red or something like that,
because you'll get mixtures
of those two colors
to determine stuff
like these code blocks.
Also, I've kind of already
jumped one of the punchlines
here, where this template
is also showing you
another package that
could be kind of thought
of as like a sister
package to bslib
called thematic, which
essentially allows you
to pretty easily
translate on some level
the CSS styles that
are going onto the page
and have those styles actually
determine new global styling
defaults for your R plots.
So to make that happen, I
just called thematic_rmd().
Since this is an R
Markdown document,
thematic has a thematic_rmd(),
where this extra setting will
also make it so that it uses the
font settings that I've set up
here in this document as well to
use that for the fonts that are
in the plot.
And the reason why this isn't
really enabled by default
is that chances are
you don't actually
have the font installed
in your R graphics device.
So thematic will actually--
in the case that it's
detected that you don't
have that font installed,
it will actually
go out and grab fonts
from Google's font API.
So if you're not
familiar, there's
a fonts.google.com
that provides you
access to hundreds,
if not thousands,
of different free fonts.
And essentially, we've tried to
design both bslib and thematic
in the sense of, if
you can find the font
on this fonts.google.com,
you don't
have to do any other work
beyond just specifying the font,
and we'll do all the work
of downloading and caching
and making sure that that
font is actually available
when people try to view your
website at the end of the day.
So there's a lot of work to
make that all that magic happen
in the background, if you've
ever worked with fonts before.
And I kind of
glossed over the fact
that there is kind
of a special way
to use Google Fonts with bslib.
If you're inside of R Markdown,
you first use this bs_theme()
function and remind
yourself, oh, yeah,
I want to change the base font.
And if you want to use this with
the normal R programming usage,
you have to remember, oh,
I want to actually use this
font_google() helper and
then give the family name.
And that's just kind of an
indication to tell bslib,
hey, this is actually
a font that I
want you to make sure the font
files are actually included
with the end website and
are actually made available
and used for that
based on setting.
Because if you were
to do it this way,
it would just change the CSS
style without actually bringing
in any of the actual font files
needed to render that font.
So yeah, that's an important
distinction to remember,
that this is the way you would
want to specify something
like this on the R
side, like with Shiny.
But this is the way you
specify it in R Markdown.
Let me just go back to a more
simple example with Shiny.
So this is kind of like the
example we saw on the home page
for bslib.
And let's just
create a navbar page
with the typical
navbar page usage.
So this is just a
simple Shiny app,
where I have two
tabs here, A and B,
and I can click back and forth
to look at page A and page B.
And that's fine.
That works just fine.
But let me actually show
you how I would actually
take this theme from
my R Markdown document
and bring that
into my Shiny app.
So I will take those arguments--
oop, try to get
multiple cursors here--
change these colons
to equal, make
sure I have commas at the end.
Base_font, remember, requires a
special font_google() function.
And do that for the base_front
and the heading_font.
And now I should be able to
run that and have the same sort
of theme look to--
whoop, something
went wrong here.
Forgot a comma-- wonder
how much my life has
been wasted on that problem.
So yeah, now we got the new
different fonts in there.
And again, like the
navbar background color
is another mixture between
this darkest black background
color that is going to be used
for the body and the foreground
color that's used for the text.
And these are just some
warnings that I actually don't
have the best contrast ratio.
And this is something that--
this is kind of like a side
thing that I think more
advanced Shiny developers
might want to know about,
that more recently, we've added
a function in Shiny called
devmode(), where we kind of set
at least a handful of different
options for you that are
convenient for developing Shiny
applications.
So I actually have this
set in my R profile,
and this is a warning
that I will only
get in Development mode that,
obviously, we don't always
want to be throwing these
warnings when you're running
this Shiny app in production.
So it's something we just like--
if we have warnings or other
things that we think only
developers should see, that's
something we'll only emit when
you have this devmode() set.
And to set it, all you need
to do is call that function.
All right, but let's do
a little bit more here.
As I mentioned,
this bs_theme()--
we really only have, like,
10 or 15 different arguments
documented here--
the Bootstrap version,
a Bootswatch theme
if you want one,
and then the more
main color and font settings.
But if you want to get more
targeted with your theming,
hopefully we have a link here--
and not a great link.
We could probably provide
a better link here
to this article.
On the bslib
website, you'll find
this dropdown has
both Bootstrap 5
and Bootstrap 4 Sass variables.
And this is a big
interactive table
with hundreds of
different theme settings
for customizing lots
of different things
that go into Bootstrap.
Just know, if you're
new to Bootstrap,
there's a lot more here
than you probably even want
to know about because there
are certain components
that Bootstrap makes available
that we, at least currently,
don't make that super
available to you in Shiny.
So there are things like--
just give you a couple of
examples-- like, in Bootstrap
itself, there are
some components
like accordions and alert
boxes and carousels,
some different
components that we
don't provide official R
wrappers for in the Shiny
package.
But some extension packages
make this stuff available.
There's a bsplus
package that has
wrapped some of these components
and some other projects
out there.
But you can also use
those things more directly
by essentially taking this
HTML to implement a carousel
and writing that in R yourself.
So if you actually wanted
to do something like that--
just to quickly show you--
you could basically copy
that HTML over and say,
I want this div with an ID
of this in a class of this
and a data-bs-ride of that.
So there is an actual R API
that Shiny provides to you
to write that same
HTML as R code
and include that
in your Shiny app.
And lots of people do that--
like write custom HTML.
So it would be possible to
just write the same HTML
and get a carousel, but I'm
not going to actually go
through a real example of that.
But just to kind of point out,
there's a whole lot of stuff
that Bootstrap exposes to you.
And that's why there's hundreds
of different Sass variables,
is because if you
search this table here
for something like
an accordion, there
are settings for setting the
padding on the accordion,
the background color,
the border width,
the border-- like, pretty much
every single, little, small
detail that would make sense
to have a high-level control
for, they'll provide it to
you through this Sass variable
theming interface.
And not only that,
we've actually
done some work to make some
common things a bit easier
for Shiny app developers.
So one thing in particular is
this navbar background color.
It's not an actual
Bootstrap thing,
but we just added it to
make your life easier,
where if you wanted to take
this basic navbar page,
and instead of-- let me
just refresh our memory here
and point out--
this kind of 50% gray
essentially being used
for the background
of this navbar,
I could set this
"navbar-bg" to "purple."
Now I have a purple
background for my navbar.
And not only that, but bslib
will do some extra work
to make sure that you get a
sensible contrast by default.
So if you wanted a
light blue instead,
notice how on this
more darker purple,
you get a light foreground color
to contrast that dark color.
But now if I do a light
color on the navbar,
it's flipped the text color
to dark instead of light.
[STRINGS STRUMMING]